je peux vous affirmer que c'est la
première fois depuis 3 ans qui existe
cette émission toutes les semaines qu'il
y a autant de questions en aussi grand
nombre il y en a quand même
quelques-unes qui disent mais pourquoi
nous parlez-vous encore de ce sujet
après 25
ans mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonsoir nous allons ouvrir ce soir le
dossier des camps de concentration de
ces camps qu'on a appelé aussi les camps
de la mort et ceux de nos invités qui
ont accepté de venir ici ce soir dans
cette émission dans cette série des
Dossiers de l'écran pour parler de ces
camps et pour répondre à vos questions
ont longtemps porté pendant des mois des
très longs mois et pendant des années
même des matricules et seulement des
matricules aussi je préfère ce soir
exceptionnellement demander à ces
invités de se présenter
eux-même ik war arrêté le 9 mars
1944 à Paris avec toute ma famille
Witz Ravensbruck nostad matricule 67
208 Bohen Jean arrêté pour fait de
résistance le 8 mars
1943 incarcéré à la prison d'Amien
jusqu'au mois de septembre 43 où je fus
dirigé premièrement sur Compigne puis
ensuite sur bukenval où on m'a attribué
le numéro matricule
21056 parti 8 jours après sur le camp de
Dora où j'ai quitté que j'ai quitté pour
aller au camp d' rich au mois d'août
1944 reparti ensuite à Dora quitté le 4
avril pour arriver à Bergen bellsen le
10 avril 45 où je fus libéré le 15 avril
45 Jean
j'ai été le numéro
81795 à
buckenvald j'ai été arrêté avec 62 de
mes camarades prêtres séminaristes je
n'étais pas prêtre à l'époque
encore au milieu d'ouvriers français à
Cologne
renani nous avions organisé différentes
choses comme une chaîne d'évasion et
puis tout ce qu'il y avait à inventer
là-bas sabotage et autres nous avons été
vendu
de mois au secret à la prison de
brweer et puis buenwald jusqu'à la
fin Roger ARN arrêté pour faire de
résistance j'étais combattant dans les
FTP arrêté le 3 février
1943 j'ai connu successivement les
prisons de la santé la prison la
centrale de poissie la centrale de Melin
la prison de Chalon surmne le C
compienne déporté à
bourenwal le 14 mai
1944cu
49594 j'ai été libéré à bourenval le 11
avril
1945 Robert ticelin arrêté à Chatu
surloire le 13 juillet 44 pour fait de
résistance incarcéré à Orléan puis
prison de freine j'ai fait partie du
dernier convoi qui a quitté Paris le 15
août 1944 passé par bukenval Dora Elric
ensuite évacué sur avensbruck évacué
draavensbruc ensuite et évadé matricule
77284 Lucienne laurenc arrêté le 7 juin
43 à Paris réseau comète évasion freine
1 an Romainville ravensbruc hen 35231
àav
Mandel Brom Charles de l'organisation
juive de combat arrêté le 19 juillet
1944 déporté le 15 août 44 bukenval Dora
Elrich matricule
l'auro George arrêté le 23 décembre 1942
pour fait de résistance interné à freine
puis compienne
matosen vin de stad buckenval Dora
ravensbru je suis resté à Dora 17 mois
mon numéro matricule est
31725 Gisel gouge j'ai été arrêté le 2
mai 1944 j'étais pour fait de résistance
j'étais étudiante à la faculté de droit
de Strasbourg qui était replié à
ClermontFerrand j'ai été emprisonné à la
prison de ClermontFerrand ensuite au
camp de Romainville puis déporté en
Allemagne au camp de neen au camp de
ravensbruc au camp de
schliben j'ai j'avais le numéro 50
4358 à
ravincebruc le roi j'ai été arrêté le 30
septembre 1943 à Vichy comme chef
départemental de la
résistance j'ai été transféré à
clermontfer
puis de là à Compigne à bourenvald puis
à Dora je portais le numéro
39439 les hommes et les femmes dont le
visage vient d'apparaître sur votre
écran qui viennent de se présenter sont
donc tous d'ancien déportés parmi les
millions d'Européens qui ont connu
l'horreur des camps de concentration il
y a eu 250000 français et sur ces 250000
Français arrêtés et déportés pendant
l'Occupation 30000 seulement ont survécu
je dis bien 30000 sur 250000 et nos
invités ici ce soir sont quelquesuns de
ces survivant ce qu'ils ont vécu ce
qu'ils ont souffert ils n'aiment guère
le raconter il est rare en effet et vous
avez pu le constater autour de vous
qu'un ancien déportés raconte facilement
je dirais presque avec complaisance la
vie des camp il est même possible que
certains de nos invités ce soir n'ai pas
tout raconé à leur propre
famille je crois qu'ils sont qu'ils se
considèrent comme dépositaire d'une
sorte de secret un secret qu'ils
essayent d'enfouir au plus profond de
leur mémoire mais le plus souvent en
vain car ils ont conscience d'avoir été
les témoins d'une des actions les plus
honteuses et les plus viles dont un
homme est pu se rendre coupable envers
l'un de ses semblables pour ceux qui
n'ont pas connu la guerre ou pour ceux
au contraire qui l'ayant connu n'ont pas
su ce qui s'était passé dans les camps
de la mort dans les camps
d'extermination ou n'ont pas voulu y
croire ces invités ce soir ont accepté
de venir porter témoignage car il y a 25
ans en effet les armées alliées venant
de l'est et de l'ouest ont libéré les
uns après les autres des camps au nom
tristement célèbre qu'il s'agisse
d'Auschwitz de burourenvald de darao et
de bien d'autres et puis des centaines
d'autres camps où des milliers d'hommes
ont péri dans les conditions les plus
affreuses ce soir le film que nous
allons vous présenter constitue l'un des
premiers témoignages il a été réalisé en
1948 soit 3 ans à peine après cette
libération et il a été réalisé par deux
femmes deux polonaises rescapé d'
Auschwitz et tous les déportés qui l'ont
vu considèrent que ce film est celui qui
convient le mieux pour ouvrir le dossier
de ce soir malheureusement et je vous
demande de nous le pardonner la qualité
de la copie que nous allons vous
présenter n'est pas tout à fait aussi
parfaite que nous l'aurions souhaité
mais il s'agit d'une copie unique en
Europe et c'est la seule que nous ayons
pu vous procurer ce
soir avant de vous laisser regarder ce
film je voudrais vous demander encore
une chose tout à l'heure j'interviendrai
très peu car je pense que le rôle du
présentateur ce soir du menur de jeu est
de rester en retrait et de vous laisser
dialoguer peut-être y y a-t-il parmi
vous à l'écoute ce soir d'ancien
d'anciens déportés et de vous laisser
donc dialoguer avec ceux qui vous
représentent ici et ceux qui vont
essayer de faire comprendre aux jeunes
générations ce qui s'est passé il y a 25
ans donc je vous demanderai
exceptionnellement de commencer à nous à
nous appeler pendant le film
c'est-à-dire que vous pouvez commencer
en gros vers 22h vers 10h du soir à
poser vos questions à guidarbois qui les
notera et qui pourra ainsi les donner
dès la fin du film voilà nous nous
retrouvons donc tout à l'heure je vous
laisse regarder ce film réalisé en 1948
par deux polonaises rescapé
[Musique]
d'Auschwitz et bien guidearbois m'a
appelé il y a un instant pour me dire
qu'il avait déjà reçu beaucoup d'appels
je vous avais en effet demandé tout à
l'heure d'appeler dès le du film enfin
des 10h des 22h et vous avez été très
nombreux à le faire guidarbois a déjà
beaucoup d'appels pour ceux d'entre vous
qui ne l'auraient pas encore fait et qui
voudrait le faire maintenant je vous
rappelle très brièvement le procédé
téléphonique que vous connaissez déjà
très bien si vous êtes à Paris vous
formez sur votre cadran svp 111 si vous
êtes si vous êtes en province et que
vous disposez de l'automatique vous
faites le 16 le 1 et ensuite svp 111 et
si vous n'avez pas l'automatique et bien
vous avez naturellement recours à
l'opératrice sans plus attendre guarbois
quelles sont les questions qui vous ont
parvenu et bien les premières questions
en fait doivent faire référence au film
et elle s'adresse à tous nos invités de
ce soir et on pourrait la donner en deux
parties cette question c'est queles
échos a réveillé en vous ce film la
projection de ce film et en deuxème
partie de question les téléspectateur
demande quel rapport exact précis avec
la réité ce film
at-il monsieur ARN je pense qu'il
faudrait demander à notre ami cnier de
répondre parce qu'elle a connu héroïne
était à heroswiz en même temps qu'elle
c'est à elle la première de parler je
crois Madame B au point de vu du film il
faut que tout le monde sache que c'est
c'est le film c'est encore en dessous de
la vérité parce que les souffrances
qu'on a enduré à c'est dans tous les
autres camp sont vraiment en dessous de
de la vérité j'ai connu mala parce que
elle était interprète et c'est grâce à
elle si je suis en vie maintenant parce
qu'elle avait en tant qu'interprète elle
pouvait nous mettre dans des commandos
plus ou
moins difficile enfin le mien elle
m'avait mis en chou commando c'estàdire
qu'il y avait un toit sur ma tête et
j'étais pas obligé de partir tous les
jours dans la neige et avec des
températures sur moins 20
degr mais on relate pas finemement dans
le film on voit pas le degré de de
déchéance à laquelle on était amené
surtout la fin
le surtout la fin et les travaux très
très durs qu'il y avait dans les
commandos à 11 commandos ce qu'on
appelait enfin en dehors les mains se
gelaient sur les briques quand il
fallait tenir les briques pour aller
travailler on pouvait plus les desserrer
tellement tellement on avait froid
tellement on se collait aux
mains il y avait
les les sélections qui était horrible
parce que réellement les sélections se
faisaient de ces manière là et cette
odeur de de de brûler toute la journée
était dans ce camp c'était affreux
affreux ce qui est aussi atroce c'est la
musique qui devait toujours jouer tel
qu'on le relaté dans le
film
enfin c'est
très c'était très très dur quoi c'est
surtout la fin et la figure des gens qui
qui marquait vraiment le on était arrivé
à une déchéance totale vous êtes resté
combien de temps dans ce camp je suis
resté 14 mois àwitz jusqu'à la libéra
avant la libération du camp quand les
Russ sont arrivés on nous a fait évacuer
le camp nous sommes parti à pied sur 200
km à pied dans la neige au mois de
janvier 45 et tous ceux qui resté en
arrière étai abattu sur
place euh quelqu'un d'entre vous veut
répondre à la question qui a été posée
ajouter quelque chose à ce qu'a dit
madame
vanagny monsieur leoi dans tous les
camps les scènes étaient à peu près les
mêmes il n'y avait guerre de différence
mais partout la souffrance était la même
et partout ce qu'on a dit dans ce qu'on
a montré dans le film est en dessous de
la
vérité monsieur je pense que c'est un
peu spécial leand
du fait que c'était un camp
d'extermination euh dans les camps où
nous sommes passés euh nous n'avons pas
vu cette extermination systématique et
dirigée sur la chambre à
gaz j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de voir ce
film ainsi de nombreux et c'est toujours
effectivement très pénible c'est pénible
parce que ça nous replace dans
l'atmosphère que nous avons vécu et
supporté pendant de longues années et au
travers ses visages expressifs et bien
il nous arrive de voir tel ou tel
camarade que nous avons laissé là-bas
euh mort dans dans les mêmes conditions
ceux qui sont exterminés par le travail
et et c'est c'est ces scènes ces scènes
atroces ces scènes euh où les où le
l'auteur campe magistralement les
procédés SS et le comportement des SS je
crois que ça euh c'est tous les camps
dans tous les camps nous avons vu les
mêmes
scènes monsieur
laabéir j'ai été frappé au retour par
l'exploitation des scènes d'horreur on a
peut-être par un goût un peu malsin de
ceux qui ne savaient pas on a illustré
surtout tel ou tel fait précis on a
parlé de la chienne de buckenval par
exemple et de bien d'autres et on au pe
près jamais exprimer l'horreur de la vie
quotidienne
être mouillé quand on n pas de quoi se
changer euh avoir faim l'appel dans la
nuit des heures au garde-à-vou des
appels nus sous la
neige tous ces détails de la vie
quotidienne qui se reproduisaient
partout chaque jour on était à la merci
d'une erreur de calcul DSS et il se
trompaient souvent dans leurs calculs et
ça durait 2h 3h indéfiniment si on avait
pu manger sa soupe avant ça allait
encore si on avait pas pu parce que le
commando était rentré trop tard alors
c'était ce qui restait froid peu importe
ça réchauffe pas une soupe à partir de
ces détails là qu'on a vécu
quotidiennement sans compter l'horreur
des situations extraordinaires mais qui
étaient des faits heureusement pas
quotidiens à bucenval du moins cette vie
terrible où on risque de se
déshumaniser ça on l'a pas dit c'est pas
facile de le
dire et puis on aime gure parler de ça
finalement non pourant il faut en parler
parce que madameag il faudrait prendre
la journée d'aller
porter du moment à laquelle il se lève
jusqu'au
soir c'est presque impossible à raconter
maintenant mais enfin il faut quand même
dire que on se levait c'était encore la
nuit on il fallait se on allait à
l'appel et l'appel durait quelquefois 2h
3h plutôt plus que 6h surtout à hwiz
quand il manquait quelqu'un il fallait
tout recommencer et tout recomter et
alors ensuite c'était le départ pour les
commandos alors quand il y avait bien un
commando bien défini qui devait aller à
tel endroit enfin que les gens savaient
où ils allaient c'était très bien mais
quand il fallait faire la chasse pour
trouver des gens pour les envoyer dehors
pour travailler dehors alors c'était des
chasses épouvantables avec la Schlag
c'était
terrible et
puis comme disait l'abéchir tout à
l'heure il pleuvait il neigeait surtout
on était dans la boue tout le temps dans
la boue il y avait toujours la faim qui
vous tiraillait parce que on mangeait
très très peu c'était juste une soupe à
midi et petite ration de pain de soir et
revenir après tremper on se recouchait
la nuit avec nos vêtements trempés on
avait pas de quoi changer c'était encore
avant de se coucher des appels
interminables qui n'en finissaient pas
je ne sais pas si on dormait 3 ou 4
heures dans la nuit c'était pas pas
d'avantage il y avait aussi des convoits
qui arrivaient on les voyait arriver les
convoits c'était la chose la plus
horrible quand nous nous arriv nous
sommes arrivés nous savions pas ce que
c'était qu'un convoie une sélection n
savions pas c'est après qu'on la su et
alors quand on attendait quand on voyait
des convois alors on avait toujours peur
de trouver quelqu'un de sa famille ou de
ses amis qui qui pouvait arriver et les
convois c'était les sélections pour
cétait atrocece c'est ce qu'il y avait
de plus
atroce je peux pas décrire ce qu'oie
parce
que j'ai eu ma mère de de gazer mes
frères ma sœur de gazer sur le moment je
m'en suis pas rendu compte quand on nous
a séparé
à l'arrivée sur le qui on ne savait pas
où on allait on mettait les vieux d'un
côté les jeunes de l'autre côté et sur
un un train de de 1000 personnes il en
rentrait pas plus d'une centaine dans le
camp et au retour je sais pas si est
rentré 10 personnes sur sur un sur un
train de 1000 personnes du départ ENF je
peux pas je trouve pas les mot tout de
suite pour pouvoir dire ça va venir
au conversation tout à l'heure mais tout
de suite je peux pas tout tout
raconter monsieur
Mandelbaum je crois qu'il faut souligner
également
la la promiscuité et la subtilité de
l'administration
SS qui avait mélangé qui avait fait un
amalgame de toutes ces
nationalités par exemple à Dora nous
étions une vingtaine de de de nations de
de citoyens de de une vingtaine de
nations mélangées et parfois on
accordait certains avantages aux uns au
détriment des autres et les capots était
nommé
euh en fonction disons de de de critères
sociaux si je peux m'exprimer ainsi en
général des droits communs des criminels
qui détestaient qui détestaient tout le
monde en particulier les résistants les
politiques et il y avait cette cette
lutte
pour la conquête si vous voulez d'un
certain pouvoir d'un certain pouvoir
administratif parce qu'en fait les SS se
contentait de superviser
l'administration du camp mais
l'administration elle-même du camp que
soit le politicheung ce département
politique o ARB statistique les
statistiques du du travail était
entièrement entre les mains de de ces
voyou et c'était d'autant plus pénible
que il n'y avait aucun contact possible
avec ces
gens et c'est ça justement qui a fait la
si on veut la la subtilité et ce qui a
provoqué probablement un gros
pourcentage de de perte qui aurait pu
être évité si on avait pu s'entendre
disons si on avait pu conquérir le le le
pouvoir dans les camps comme comme ça
s'est passé en 1944 en 1944 que ce soit
à burnwald ou que ce soit à Dora et bien
finalement ce sont les éléments
politiques si vous voulez qui ont
supplanté les éléments de droit commun
et je crois que là les mes camarades
sont d'accord avec moi pour le dire
monsieur ARN je suis tout à fait
d'accord
avec mais pour répondre à la question
qui était posée je pense qu'il faut dire
que l'histoire qui raconté est
absolument
authentique mais on n'a pas pu mettre
dans le film Le pire parce que les camp
c'était encore pire que ça et c'est vrai
que depuis le retour il est
déporté par le de ces choses
ou quelquefois lorsqu'ils en ont parlé
devant certains
témoins ils ont senti le scepticisme
voire le la dénégation en disant vous
exagre
c'est tout de même pas ça et bien c'est
encore pire que ce n'était dans le
film Monsieur la je crois qu'il y a tout
de même des gradations dans les camps le
premier camp dans lequel j'ai été
interné c'était le camp de matosen et
matosen pour moi ça été l'élimination
systématique de l'individu mais alors
d'une façon froide
systématique et ensuite je suis allé à
Viner stad qui est était un commando de
matosen et là lorsque nous sommes
arrivés nous avons été reçu par le chef
de camp qui nous a tenu ce langage
suivant vous êtes ici pour travailler
celui qui ne travaille pas ne mange pas
avec le travail que j'exige de vous et
la nourriture que je vous donne vous
devez vivre 6 mois si au bout de 6 mois
vous êtes encore en vie ce que vous avez
volé votre nourriture et par conséquent
j'ai sur vous le droit de VI ou de
mort
et lorsque vinad a été
bombardé nous avons été transférés à
binval et dans le train qui nous emmena
less nous dit mais vous allez dans un
sanatorium effectivement nous avons
pensé et mes camarades et moi que la vie
était tout de même beaucoup moins dure
si vous voulez nous étions moins mal
nourri si vous voulez à buenval pu adora
que nous l'étions à matosen ou à vuner
de
Stal par conséquent il y avait bien une
espèce de gradation dans le dans les
camps madame laurentinos m'a paru le le
plus terrible de tous oui il y avait
certainement une gradation dans les
camps mais cette dégradation provenait
aussi des chefs que l'on avait dans les
camps du commandant de camp et des
officerines et des postaines dans ce
tout petit camp de h au début nous avons
avons V un commandant de camp qui se
disait un peu trop généreusement tout de
même notre père à tout c'était beaucoup
c'était nous n'aurions pas souhaité une
telle
paternité et un petit peu plus tard il a
été remplacé sans doute parce qu'il
était trop paternel avec nous paternité
nous apprécions peu et à ce moment-là
est venu un nouveau commandant
accompagné d'une officeine d'z madame
justement et c un
officeine voulu prouver qu'elle
connaissait son métier et qu'elle le
connaissait bien la vie n'était Dieu
sait pas plaisante à partir de ce
moment-là les fouilles se sont multiplié
les épouillages ce sont multipliés par
10 les prétendu douche ce sont également
c'est-à-dire la douche c'està-dire qu'on
partait à 4h du matin dans la nuit qu'on
marchait dans la neige qu'on arrivait à
l'usine du camp que là on nous prenait
tous nos tous nos vêtements pour les
passer à les Tuves et que quand on nous
les remettait alors qu'on avait grelotté
dans les couloirs bah ces vêtements bah
ils étaient tout mouillés bien entendu
ils étaient soit-disant propre mais ils
étaient trempés et ainsi de suite et
cette dame off F sine d'jit a pensé que
puisqu'elle avait été àj et benchelle
elle allait faire mieux elle a dit ben
vous allez
voir nous on va vous tatouer sur le
front je dois dire qu'il y a eu vraiment
une terreur panique qui s'est répandu
dans notre petit C enfin notre petit C
nous étions environ 700 donc à peu près
400 françaises et il est certain que
malgré tout au départ je suis tout à
fait de votre avis c'était les détenus
eux-mêmes qui faisaient la loi ça il n'y
a malheureusement aucun doute et c'est
at trro à dire c'est at TR à dire mais
il y avait quand tout d'un coup le le
commandement du cancer duriss soit parce
qu'on avait reçu des ordres de
flossenbourg qu'il fallait faire mieux
encore soit par tendance personnelle
tout simplement ben la vie pouvait
devenir réellement du jour au lendemain
encore plus intenable qu'elle n'était je
crois que là tout le monde éit à
aussi guidearbois je pense qu'on peut
passer à d'autres questions d'autant que
vous en avez beaucoup je crois oui il y
en a beaucoup sur la vie quotidienne nos
invités en ont déjà beaucoup parlé mais
ils ont nos correspondants ont déjà
réagi à des mots à des phrases qu'on
prononçait par exemple madame Vardi ou
laabéchire et Madame Vardi a parlé de
déchéance laabéchire a parlé de
déshumanisation et nos correspondants
demande est-ce que cette déchéance était
totale est-ce qu'il ne restait pas une
étincelle de dignité au fond de
vous-même
heureusement heureusement on aurait pas
pu on ser pas là oui on serait pas là la
déchéance bien sûr c'est que il faut
dire que dans ces camp on avait ouvert
toutes les prisons de d'Allemagne ou
surtout à hwitz on avait envoyé tous les
les assassins les les voleurs et c'est
eux qui qui avaient le le commandement
du camp si vous voulez c'était les
capots
et aussi nous étions mélangés c'était un
camp où il y avait 100000
personnes des Polonais des Russes des
Français des Hongrois personne ne
parlait de la même langue et on était
arrivé justement à à mettre toutes ces
personnes on nétait pas en contact les
unes les autres moi j'étais avec des des
Polonaises ou avec des des allemandes je
comprenais absolument pas ce qu'on me
disait il y avait aucun moyen d'échange
de communiquer de de de parler c'était
pas possible
enfin je me suis trouvée avec une amie
française une seule jeune fille enfin
jeune femme comme moi que je ne
connaissais pas avec qui je me suis lié
d'amitié et c'est grâce à ça qu'on a pu
tenir et qu'on a pu revenir mais c'était
ça la déchéance c'était
euh quand nous allions chercher la soupe
c'était des des des cubes de 50 L enfin
c'était très très lour à porter il y
avait là des
d'autres détenus qui étaient affamés
aussi qui se jetaient sur nous et à coup
de bâton qui nous prenait notre soupe on
pouvait vraiment pas se défendre contre
contre ça on était forcé de laisser la
soupe et pu de partir tout ce qu'on
pouvait faire ça on était battu on était
roué enfin même entre nous enfin
terrible à dire mais entre déportés il y
avait là toutes sortes de gens qui
étaient déportés c'est à ça que les
Allemands voulaient arriver ils
voulaient entre nous-même on
s'entretue mais c'est parce que
justement on est resté quand
même digne
enfin on a pu résister il fallait avoir
le moral ceux qui n'ont pas eu le moral
ce qui pas que le moral il y a eu
souffrances physiques aussi on pouvait
pas lutter contre le Tyfus on pouvait
pas lutter contre contre toutes les
infections qu'il y avait au corps
c'était pas possible contre l'époux
contre tout c'est pour ça que beaucoup
beaucoup de gens sont morts et puis
surtout la fin la fin la fin il y avait
des des personnes qui sont rentrées au
camp toutes sont rentrées bien portantes
mais quand à auchevit on a ouvert les
portes il y avait beaucoup de personnes
qui pesaient que 27 kg 26 kg et moi-même
je pisais 27 kg quand je suis sortie du
corps monsieur
Lab je crois que il est certain que le
régime des grandes concentration avait
un but de
dépersonnalisation et tendait à
déshumaniser nous tous qui y étions et
tous nos camarades qui sont restés C
dshumanisation c'était le numéro on
avait plus de nom il fallait répondre à
un numéro et et rapidement euh le
costume
euh la façon de couper les cheveux un
mois la rue au milieu du crâne la strass
le mois suivant la crête comme des
chevaux de
cirque des gens à qui on ne parle plus
que par cri par ordre des des
gueulements mais rien d'humain et puis
tout bêtement avoir
faim
j'ai quand je fais quand je me rappelle
certaines expériences j'ai été tenté de
voler le pain de camarade quand on crève
de faim cette tentation de récupérer ce
que l'on
peut
heureusement je crois que l'isolé était
perdu d'une certaine façon ce qui nous a
fait tenir ce sont toute une série de
relations de petits groupes où l'on
s'épaulait les uns les autres il arrivé
à tout le monde de connaître un jour ou
l'autre un moment de cafare un moment de
faiblesse le fait d'en parler le le
camarade qui venait et puis qui vous
montait jusqu'à la place d'appel le
petit geste de rien c'était
énormeueer simplement à dire
bonjour ces petits gestes de la vie
quotidienne qu'on maintenait dans un
univers qu'on voulait
brutal et cetera on pourrait prendre
tant et tant
d'exemples je crois aussi qu'il faut
parler de la torture morale c'est qu'il
n'y avait pas que la torture physique
alors un exemple par exemple au candelic
à Noël 44 il y avait un grand sapin sur
la d'appel ce sapin était entièrement
décoré de lampe électrique et en
rentrant du travail nous rentrions de V
Leben qui se trouvait à plusieurs
kilomètres et nous rentrions à pied dans
la neige avec une pierre sur l'épaule
puisqu'il fallait apporter sa pierre
pour la cour du camp nous a fait rester
au garde à vous dans cette nu Noël
autour du sapin et je connais énormément
de camarades que ça a marqué
terriblement et beaucoup d'ailleurs
s'étaient fixé cette date d'honneurant
je tiendrai jusque là il y a pas de
doute que le moral y était pour quelque
chose parce que Noël s'est passé est
arrivé il ne s'est rien passé il y a des
camarades qui ne qui sont morts mais
comme ça simplement parce que c'était
passé la date était passée et c'est ça
qui est terrible cette cette torture
morale d'une nuit de Noël passée autour
d'un sapin pour beaucoup ça évoquait
tellement de choses que il y en a qui
n'ont pas tenu mon B moi je pense que
nous nousetons ce soir à la chose à
laquelle nous nous hons depuis que nous
sommes
rentrés c'est l'impossibilité de
transmettre et de traduire euh c'était
de mondes absolument différents euh ici
c'est ici avec un vocabulaire qui
représente des choses qui représente des
sentiments et le camp pour nous c'était
là-bas c'était là-bas et c'est quelque
chose absolument d'intraduisible nous
nous heurtons nous avons l'habitude les
uns et les autres de vouloir en parler
notamment aux jeunes et bien c'est très
difficile et nous avons l'impression et
bien que nous avons failli à notre
devoir quand nous avons terminé cette
causerie parce que c'est cette vie
journalière oui c'est extraordinaire un
mononde de
cadavre des suppliciers qui sont pendus
et bien ça frappe mais quand on évoque 6
he d'appel et bien personne personne ne
le ressent personne ne le ressem quand
on évoque un morceau de pain perdu ou un
morceau de pain volé et cette tentation
de prendre un morceau de pain quel est
celui d'entre nous celle d'entre nous
qui l'a pas senti une fois et au moment
au moment de faire cette solidarité
quand on je demandz une cuillèe de
souple ou un morceau de pain et bien il
faut situer les choses dans le contexte
où elles étaient on passe dans les rues
maintenant on voit du pain dans les
poubelles mais là nous avions 100 g de
pain c'était une chose qui était
absolument indispensable pour vivre
quelques jours et bien on nous a
demandéit d'en donner 10 g pour
quelqu'un qui était plus atteint que
nous et bien personne d'entre nous l'a
fait spontanément absolument personne
l'a fait spontanément il y a eu cette
réaction d'égoïsme qui est qui est
quelque chose d'humain et et la grande
la grande victoire et bien c'est que
nous l'avons fait la grande victoire
c'est que tous nous l'avons fait et
c'est ça c'est ça justement le but le
but des SS et bien c'était d'avilir
d'avilir l'homme euh pour le rendre
abject vis-à-vis de lui-même vis-à-vis
de ses camarades déportés pour donner
d'autant plus de force au bourreau on
frappe beaucoup plus facilement
quelqu'un qui semble adjc que quelqu'un
qui est digne et je pense que cette
expérience du camp et bien il y a
d'autres choses à en parler qui sont
au-delà des tortures qui sont au-delà
des statistiques de la mortalité mais
qui sont en définitive et bien la
victoire la victoire de l'individu
l'individu qui est pétri de de notions
qui ont été inculpé par la civilisation
et puis en réalité et bien entre les
bourreaux et ceux qu'on présente comme
des victimes et qui représentai l'homme
et bien ce sont les victimes qui on
gagné et nous sommes ici pour en
témoigner parce que sans ces notions
sans ces notions cherrement acquis
chèement défendu et bien pas un d'entre
nous serait rentré et pas un pourrait
nen parler et peut-être bien que la
chose n'aurait pas exister à l'heure
actuelleir et bien je je pense que nos
invités ne peuvent pas en vouloir aux
téléspectateurs qui leur posent des
questions si simples sur la vie
quotidienne que quelle était le nombre
d'heures de travail par jour le nombre
de jours par semaine la composition des
repas les heures des
repas monsieur le j'appartenais à un
commandau d'électricien au tunnel de
Dora et nous travaillons 12h par
jour il y avait deux commandau un
commandoau de français et un commando de
russe des chiches des chiches le chiche
de jour le chiche de nuit et nous
travaillons donc 12 par
jour nous avions en principe 12 he de
repos mais ça n'était jamais 12 he de
repos puisqu'il y avait toutes les les
séances de désinfection de dépouillage
enfin c'était infernal N- pas et il y
avait une journée le jour où on
changeait de brigade si on peut dire
nous avions une journée de repos c'était
le
dimanche mais malgré tout c'était tout
de même 12h par J c'était he par jour
soit de jour soit de nuit et les appels
oui mais les appels venaient dans les
heures de repos les appels étaient pris
sur les heures de repos et quelque foois
ça représentait 3h 4h c'est ça on avait
même pas avait je P quelquefois 4 5h de
repos surt par jour il fallait
travailler C 12h les app di le dimanche
oui je voulais dire au camp d' richich
nous travaillons nous à V Leben qui
était à côté de Dora et bien
dans les derniers mois avant nous y
allons par le train en wagon et il n'y
avait plus de voie utilisable al nous
allions à pied ça faisait plusieurs
kilomè pour aller plusieurs kilomè pour
revenir et le soir comme je vous l'avais
dit avec une pierre sur l'épaule alors
nous partions le matin de très bonne
heure pour pouvoir faire justement ces
12 heures de travail nous partions à
pied dans la neige nous faisions notre
journée nous attendions après un moment
encore à voffleben nous reprenions la
route à pied avec notre pierre sur
l'épaule nous rentrions au qu il y avait
l'appel et ça se termina environ vers
11h ou minuit à 11h auou minuit on
touchait notre litre de soupe très clair
le petit morceau de pain et on se
dépêchait de boire le lites de soupe et
manger le morceau de pain de peur qu'on
nous le vole dans la nuit et on se
couchait donc vers minuit et à 4h 4h30
du matin comme il fallait refaire la
route à pied on recevait à nouveau de de
grand coup de tric pour se lever
rapidement et aller s'aligner et
repartir à pied alors voilà les journées
et la semaine qui était toujours comme
ça
madame gouche dans le camp où j'étais
àli c'était également la même chose nous
avions 12 heur de travail une semaine de
jour une semaine de nuit des au retour
des appels interminables et le dimanche
souvent tout l'après-midi en
appelle je dois
ajouter à propos de du Candel rich où
j'étais également où était monsieur
Tiercelin il est arrivé 3000 français en
deux convois deux convois de 1500 hommes
le premier convoi a pratiquement été
anilé le deuxème convoi de la série des
77000 ce convoi qui est parti de freine
le 15 août sur ce convoi de 1500 1500
hommes sont rentrés 32 hommes et sur ces
32 hommes et bien nous sommes
actuellement une
poignée je dois dire une poignée et
c'est c'est tout monsieur borine j'étais
dirigé comme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure
dans la
présentation sur Dora dès mon arrivée à
buckenval et ce au mois d'octobre
1943 Dora c'était l'usine souterraine où
on a fabriqué DV2 par la suite et quand
nous sommes arrivés à Dora au mois de
septembre il y avait pas de camp le camp
consistait en un tunnel et nous sommes
arrivés à 10h du soir nous avons
commencé à travailler à minuit il y
avait donc pas de cuisine il y avait pas
de bloc il y avait absolument rien nous
avons eu pendant 15 jours 3 semaines
un/4 de rueabaga crue et
puis un peu un peu de pain et nous avons
travaillé là-dedans 12 12 heur par jour
dans l'obscurité pour la plupart parce
que ce n'était pas électrifié c'était
des lampas et C hè et sans voir le jour
évidemment sans water absolument sans
water sans boisson et pour donner une
statistique le candora a au mois de
novembre occupé 3000 déportés et dans le
mois de novembre il en est mort 1680 sur
3000 puison peut pas r justement c'est
c'est le froid c'est la fin c'est la
sensation on ne peut ça ne peut pas
s'expliquer on peut pas le faire tir
c'est ça
qu'on de la sélection nous avons je vous
interroms une seconde et je vous prie de
m'en excuser mais nous avons reçu nous
recevons nous continuons à recevoir à
svp des centaines et des centaines
d'appels donc je crois que maintenant
vous avez pu monsieur Bohen l'a très
bien dit tout à l'heure essayez
d'exprimer vos sentiments essayez de
nous faire comprendre ce qui s'est passé
il y a quelques 25 ans al je vais vous
demander de bien vouloir accepter de
répondre maintenant brièvement à toutes
les questions qui sont sont posé par les
téléspectateurs et je crois que ainsi le
vœu de Monsieur Bohen sera peut-être
exaucé et qu'on pourra à l'aide de vos
réponses les plus nombreuses et les plus
breves possibles faire comprendre ce que
c'était là-bas comme vous disiez tout à
l'heure monsieur benen
guarbire et bien il y a un terme qui a
beaucoup frappé l'esprit des
téléspectateurs c'est celui de Capo
comment devenait-on capo demande un
correspondant de Cap Breton et au prix
de quelles conditions monsieur manelbum
et bien capo c'est l'abréviation du mot
allemand qui veut dire 47 polizï 47 qui
veut dire concentration de slager et
polizï que tout le monde connaît
c'est-à-dire policier du camp il y avait
en fait deux types de policiers du camp
il y avait les capots qui étaient les
policiers des commandos de travail et il
y avait les lager shoots qui étaient les
policiers à l'intérieur du camp pour
faire régner l'ordre à l'intérieur du
camp
comment on devenait capau et bien
simplement par ses
aptitudes à frapper n'importe qui il
fallait avoir déjà de bons antécédents
de criminels pour devenir un capot à
part ça il est arrivé que finalement à
la fin autour de
1944 certains Français soient devenus
des capots mais on ne frappait
pratiquement plus à Dora à partir de ce
moment-l et à quand les politiques aussi
bien français qu'allemand ont pris la
direction du camp les lagers shoots et
les
capot se sont humanisés disons est-ce
qu'ils voulaient se dédoiner pour enfin
à l'origine c'était des criminel qu'il
soit tchck qu'il soit polonais en
particulier ukrainien Tigan nous avons
connu un Tigane adora our plutôt qui
tuait tous les matins un homme pour se
faire la main
euh on ne peut pas dire que c'était des
êtres absolument normaux n'est-ce pas
voilà le le critère à peu près la
description du capot qui était
parfaitement nourri d'ailleurs qui
possédait des bottes et qui dormait dans
une pièce
particulière svp
non en quoi consistait-elle et comment
avez-vous passer au travers avez-vous pu
passer au travers de ces sélections
madameag
enfin bien dire sélectionné donc on
mettait d'un côté les gens aptes à
travailler ou du moins qu'on supposait
apte à travailler tous les autres
étaient envoyés au four crématoire gazé
d'abord et ensuite
brûlé ensuite il y avait des sélections
dans le camp lui-même lorsque le détenu
était malade ou avait était musulman ce
qu'on appelait musulman
c'était le détenu qui était très très
très maigre on l'appelait musulman et
alors ça c'était horrible dès que une
personne se sentait musulmane elle osait
même plus se montrer de peur de passer à
la sélection d'être choisi comme dans le
film d'ailleurs à coup de de Schlag pour
être envoyé au four crématoire il y
avait aussi des sélections dans les
hôpitaux quand on était malade on allait
à l'hôpital du moins on évitait d'aller
à l'hôpital je suis passée dans une
sélection
et le le docteur qui
il a fait passer devant lui tout le
monde il a choisi toutes les personnes
qui étaient plus ou moins valides nous
sommes restés à 6
sur dans dans le rivire où il y avait je
sais pas 500 personnes à ce moment-là
cétais uniquement parce
que vous étiez apte à pouvoir encore
continuer à travailler jusqu'à
accisement les élections se faisaient
automatiquement comme ça on choisissait
les plus malades les plus plus les plus
infirmes
svp les questions sont nombreuses à
propos des expériences médicales dont on
a beaucoup parlé en quoi consistait-elle
et est-ce qu'un de nos invités y a
assisté monsieur ça alors
là au bourenval il y avait un bloc des
cobail qui s'appelait le bloc 46 et
généralement ceux qui entrai mais n'en
sortait
pas on y faisait essentiellement des
expériences sur le Tyfus ainsi que
d'autres expériences telles que sur les
brûures au phosphore ou des choses de ce
genre
et évidemment sil faut
répondre d'y avoir assisté ça bien sû
que c'est pas possible personne en
général N sont pas sorti y avait le bloc
10 le bloc sélections de des expériences
des expériences alors là on choisissait
souvent des jumeaux pour pour
expérimenter sur ces sur les jumeaux si
ils avaient les mêmes réactions au mêmes
piqû ou au même on leur injectait des
piqures pour savoir comment s'il
réagissaiit de la même façon ou s'ils
devaiit mourir ensemble s en un qui
mourait si l'autre mourrait
aussi il y a eu beaucoup beaucoup ou
d'expérience à itz on a pratiqué des
expériences sur beaucoup de
femmes pour les
stérilisations aussi il en a de rentré
ouiav aussi quelqu de
rentré et il y a eu enfin moi ça ma
tellement frappé il y avait elle
n'appartenait pas à notre camp mais à
côté une femme qui était entièrement
couverte de poil elle avait une figure
toute vue et un jour on est venu la
chercher et elle a disparu et on l'a
plus jamais revu il est certain que
cette femme ne devait pas glandulerement
être absolument normal et que c'était un
sujet extraordinaire d'étude et par la
suite j'ai vu mais alors en liberté en
yoslavie une yoslave qui avait été COBAT
à qui on avait fait des greffes
incroyables elle avait des jambes ses
jambes n'étaient plus qu'une cicatrice
et elle m'a dit on m'a donné le caner je
ne sais pas si on le lui avait donné
mais le fait est qu'elle l'avait svp
oui depuis le début de cette émission on
parle des victimes et des bourreaux mais
il y a de temps en temps beaucoup de
questions sur les bourreaux et il y a
celle-ci que je trouve
importante est-ce que vous pourriez nous
décrire le regard d'un
bourreau non absolument pas très
variable absolument pas il s'agissait
simplement de fonctionnair de la police
allemande qui avait été formé dans un
premier temps à l'École supérieure de
police de Potsdam et qui était ensuite
passé par le camp mer de la SS qui était
à
sacenosen Oranienbourg dans la banlieu
de de enfin très près de Berlin ils
faisaient leur travail disons entre
guillemets ils avaient les mêmes
problèmes qu'un qu'un industriel de
Chicago qui doit faire de de de de la
charcuterie en pour eux c'était un
problème de rentabilité d'ailleurs le
film l'a parfaitement
montré moi je pense que certains livres
aussi l'ont montré il y aalire la mort
et mon métier ou certaines CH Oui quand
l'interrogatoire de
he qui était le dernier commandant connu
de de Auschwitz a
démontré que en fait c'est un métier
comme s'il était poinonneur de
msum il avait un métier il avait un
métier il était absolument fanatique du
du parti nazi et pour lui cette
extermination ça rentrait parfaitement
s' cadrait parfaitement avec son rôle de
fonctionnaire une sorte de technicien
c'était un technicien de de du du
meurtre en masse qu'ils appellent eux le
le mass murder exactement et qui prenaz
plaisiris à poser une question je
voudlais vous présenter avant à nos
téléspectateur vous n'étiez pas là au
début de l'émission monsieur Declerc
vous nous avez appelé vous avez appelévp
pendant le film exact et nous avons
demandé de venir parce que vous
étiez à l'époque en 1944 c'est exact
vous étiez engagé dans l'armée
américaine vous êtes français mais vous
étiez engagés dans l'armée américaine et
vous
avez participé dans les premier
commandau à la libération du camp de
benvald je pense avoir été le premier
Français à être entré à benvald c'est
exact en au mois d'avril ou enfin je ne
sais pas exactement quelle date c'était
un une petite esquette de SC cars comme
on les appelle qui faisait partie de la
3è armée américaine du 20e corps et je
pense avoir été le premier Français à
rentrer làdedans mais j'aimerais
énormément vous poser une question qui
est la suivante et qui me me chipote
terriblement mon impression évidemment a
été atroce car j'étais très jeune je
n'avais pas notion ni idée de qu de
concentration quelle qu'il soit donc ça
a été un petit peu une découverte pas un
petit peu mais beaucoup une découverte
et une espèce de stade d'horreur
et il y avait beaucoup de Français à
benwald et j'avoue que ce qui
m'a surtout je dirais choqué dans dans
le sens propre du terme c'est que on
est il n'y a pas eu d'espèce d'exubérant
si vous voulez de
libération j'entends bien c'est pas un
français un Américain que ça soit un
russe ou autre ça n absolument aucune
importance il n'y a il y a eu il y a eu
un passage à vide euh qui a duré
euh une semaine puisque j'y suis resté
une semaine dans dans le cercle euh où
les gens ne ne réalisaient pas que
c'était fini que ça avait commencé que
que ça pourrait recommencer ou que ça
allait recommencer dans l'autre sens
enfin c'était assez étonnant c'est c'est
très curieux si vous voulez alors
j'aimerais que quelqu'un puisse me
donner une réponse là-dessus euh vous
comprenez cette n'est pas comme le
condamné à mort où on va faire sauter la
porte de sa prison et puis on sort et on
dit mon vieux tu es libre non il y a eu
là une espèce de passage à vide c'est
comme ça que je peux l'exprimer je pense
où les gens ne réalisaient pas qui que
quoi et comment enfin bref ça a été un
un blanc et c'est une chose qui m'a
toujours étonné et qui m'étonne encore
alors si vous pouvez me donner une
réponse j'aimerais beaucoup la connaître
ben je peux je peux répondre même assez
longuement sur la question j'étais là
mais euh
pour il y a quelque chose et moi aussi
qui m'échappe dans ce que vous dites il
faudrait qu'on puisse savoir exactement
le jour et l'heure que vous êtes venus
alors é la première la première les
premiers Américains que nous avons vu
c'était le 11 avril vers 4h de
l'après-midi moi je pense que
ça une colonne blindée un scoc ah il
était non il y avait au moins 5 ah non
alors c'est pas les premiers premier
c'est une colonne blindée il était
composé d'environ une dizaine de chars
il ne il ne se sont pas arrêtés enfin
ils sont venus jusque devant le camp oui
ils ont poursuivi leur chemin et ils ont
été libéré vmar qui été libéré quelques
heur plus tard oui et c'est seulement
après que
des mais mais à ce moment-là la
libération du camp elle était faite pour
nous elle était faite depuis midi
exactement les et depuis 2h de
l'après-midi le le les les détenus
c'étaient libérés eux-mêmes et puis en
plus il faut penser qu'il y a eu pendant
les 10 jours qui s'étaient passés une
une une atmosphère qui était extrêmement
différente de la vie habituelle du camp
de toutes les évacuations qui avait eu
quand les évacuations se
sontarê arrêté le 9 avril il a a il y a
eu une atmosphère nouvelle qui s'est
créée un silence qui planait là-dessus
et on a préparé l'opération Armée de
libération du camp et et le moment
d'exubérance il a eu lieu à ce moment-là
et vous êtes sans doute arrivé quelques
heures après ou dans ou dans la soirée
mais les les troupes américaines qui
sont venus pour occuper le camp pour
pour prendre possession du camp oui
parce que le lendemain on a était
pratiquement livré à nous-même il y
avait il y avait plus personne il y
avait il venait juste une jeep avec
quelques officiers de liaison des choses
comme ça il y a venu des journalistes
des des reportes de presse mais les
l'unité américaine qui est venue pour
prendre possession du C de bourenval et
des détenus et apportter des des vivres
c'est seulement le 13 avril à midi entre
cette le moment où les chars américains
qui ont passé dans le coin sont passés
et où où réellement on est venu occuper
le camp c'est passé 2
jours monsieur labégir jeis raconter
deux faits au moment de la libération du
camp c'estàdire le 11 avril j'étais au
revir non pas l'hôpital du camp mais les
baraques où on essayait de soigner les
malades qui étaient entassés
là on a entendu du révire le qu'il y
avait une bataille des coups de feu on a
appris très vite que le camp se libérait
mais il aurait fallu voir à ce moment-là
et filmer le moment de folie que ça a
été dans le revire dans le revire nous
n'avions pas une tenue complète nous
avions droit simplement à une chemise et
bien tout le monde se baladant en
chemise un unijambise que je revois mais
sautant sur la seule jambe qu'il avait
hein et mais c'était délirant je ne peux
pas l'évoquer comme cela hein c'est un
premier fait un deuxième fait c'est que
très vite il y a eu une ambiance
j'allais dire une un peu de crainte et
de terreur parce que on était libre
c'est vrai mais ce qu'on craignait c'est
que les Allemands envoient bombarder le
camp le camp qu'il n'avait pas pu faire
sauter dont il n'avait pas pu incendier
ni les baraques ni brûler les déportés
qui restaient vivant nous étions plus
que 21000 je crois bien à ce moment-là
environ
et on vivait dans une erreur et les
avions américains qui passaient les
armées les avions militaires qui
passaient audessus de nous on ne savait
jamais ce que c'était n'était-ce pas un
retour des Allemands voulant tout
liquider ce qui expliquerait un peu que
vous n'ayez pas trouvé une ambiance
délirante si vous êtes arrivé quelqu
j'ai trouvé une ambiance qui n'était pas
d'ambiance monsieur ça n'est même pas
une ambiance délirante ou négative ou
positive c'est pas d'ambiance du tout on
a eu l'impression si vous voulez que la
chose continuait
euh je garde encore cette impression
voyez-vous c'estàdire qu'autrement dit
le les règles du camp continuaient à
l'époque où elles étaient avant que je
ne les ai connu puisque je ne les ai pas
connu moi dans dans le sens où vous tous
les avez connu mais on a eu l'impression
que si vous voulez le fait que ça soit
libéré ou non il y avait encore le modi
vivandi qui qui restait indépendamment
du fait que vous n'aviez plus les les
les type sur leur tour avec leur
mitrailleuse c'est vous avez quand même
probablement pu voir immédiatement que
la cour du faux crématoire était bourrée
de cadavres nuus entassés je l'ai vu et
on ramassait des camarades tous les
jours et c'était cette chose atroce
d'être libéré et chaque jour des
camarades libres mourent et ne reverrait
pas la France c'était atroce je pense
qu'on a répondu je pense qu'on a répondu
à la question que pouvait se poser
monsieur Declerc en en pénétrant pour la
première fois dans ce brenv je si vous
le permettez que nous retournions à svp
pour d'autres questions gu et bien il y
a une des très très grandes questions
qui a été évoquée très souvent et même
dans des romans célèbres elle est
celle-ci comment peut-on expliquer que
dans cet univers concentrationnaire il
n'y a presque jamais eu de rébellion et
une autre correspondante ajoute pourquoi
est desporté qui étaiit emmené à la
chambre à gaz ne se défendit ne se
défendait-il pas autant mourir en se
battant dit-elle ce qu' n avait pas de
mitrailleuse se battre avec quoi on
pouvait pas se battre avec des points
des points très faibles de de gens qui
pesaient 30 kg au moment où il où la la
question se posait et on ne pouvait pas
se battre contre des gens armés autre
chose aussi qu'on ne dit pas on ne
disait pas qu'on allait à la chambre à
gaz personne n savait rien personne n'en
savait rien on nous emmenait à la douche
pour nous pour nous pour prendre un bain
pour prendre une douche et une fois
qu'on nous enfermait enfin qu'on nous
enfermait par moi bien sûr qu'on
enfermait les gens sous prétexte de leur
faire prendre une douche on glissait des
cartouches de de gaz par les cheminées
qui étaient donc àwitz et on on gazait
tous les gens donc il n'y avait pas il
pouvait pas y avoir rébellion et comment
pouvait-il y avoir rébellion quand on
emmenait des femmes avec des enfants se
se battre contre quoi contre qui avec
quoi des mitraillettes au point c'était
pas possible c'est ce que les gens ne
peuvent pas comprendre il faut leur
faire comprendre ceci on ne pouvait pas
se battre je ne sais pas moi je v donner
un exemple est-ce que les prisonniers
français à la fin de la guerre quand on
les a emmené dans les camps ils
pouvaient se battre c'était quand même
des soldats est-ce qu'ils se sont battus
ils sont allés dans les camps de
prisonniers et bien pour les femmes
c'était la même chose pour les pour les
les gens qu'on déportait on leur disait
pas où on les emmenait on leur disait on
va vous emmener autre part et puis c'est
tout quand on nous a enfermé dans les
camps dans les dans les wagons de à
bestion on nous a enfermé c'était scellé
quelle rébellion voulez on pouvait il
pouvait pas y avoir de rébellion on n
allait pas comme des bêtes à l'abattoir
bien sûr c'est pas vra parce que on ne
pensait jamais
que que l'Allemagne pouvait faire des
choses pareilles c'était pas possible
c'était impensable c'était impensable
svp mais s'il n'a pu pas pu y avoir de
rébellion c'est encore une
correspondante qui pose cette question
avez-vous au moins pensé au
suicide Monsieur Arnaud non oui il y a
eu des gens effectivement qui se sont
suicidés qui se sont jetés sur les files
de fer électriques pour mettre fin à
leur
souffrance mais je voudrais revenir sur
cette histoire de pourquoi on s'est pas
révolté et bien on ne s'est pas révolté
tant qu'on ne pouvait pas le faire mais
quand on pouvait le faire on le faisait
et c'est ainsi que les gens de Treblinka
le 2 at
1943 après une très longue préparation
sachant qu'il en sortirait d'ailleurs
sûr de ne pas pouvoir en sortir vivant
après une longue préparation pendant de
nombreux mois ont passé à une
insurrection
armée qui a abouti d'ailleurs à la
liquidation du camp qui n'a jamais pu
refonctionner qui a été complètement
liquidé au mois de novembre
suivant une longue préparation qui
repose en gros sur ceci ils ont détecté
l'endroit où le où se trouvait le dépôt
d'armes des
SS et ils ont préparé longuement comment
il pourrait atteindre ce dépôt d'armes
et lorsque la question le la chose était
au point ça a étéit possible ils l'ont
fait et ils se sont
batttu jusqu'à la mort d'ailleurs il
n'est ressorti que 60 à 80 survivants
dans ce camp où le nombre des morts est
d'au moins 700000 et qui n'a fonctionné
guerre plus de 14 mois à soibor il y a
eu aussi une insurrection armée et dans
de nombreux C il y a eu des
organisations qui ont pensé à cela parce
que beaucoup pensaient croyaient
savaient que les SS ne voulait pas
laisser les camp se
libér être être libéré et dans ces
conditions dans la mesure où c'était
possible là où c'était possible ça pas
été possible dans tous les camp mais
dans tous les cas où il y a eu des
possibilités une résistance à armée qui
est d'ailleurs la continuation de la
solidarité entre les déportés elle a
existé elle a existé à matosen elle a
existé à Daso elle a existé à saxanosen
elle a existé à bourenval et à bourenval
elle a eu la possibilité de de se
manifester réellement monsieur Bor moi
je voulais retenir de la première
question une phrase autant mourir en se
battant et bien je voudrais ici aborder
un sujet très peu connu et c'est une
question de sabotage et qui a pris une
particulièrement importance au cant
d'ora où mes camarades étaient aussi je
l'ai dit je le répète le camp d'ora
c'était une usine où on fabriquait les
V1 puis par la suite les V2 or on sait
que l'état-major allemand et bien misit
absolument sur la baise au point de CV2
pour gagner la guerre CV2 qui devait
anéantir
l'Angleterre et bien au camp d'ora euh
on a plus on estime que 9000 V2 ont été
construites et que moins d'un diè ont
atteint leur but et bien les raisons
sont simples les raisons et bien c'est
une bataille de déportter c'est une
bataille de déportter une bataille
constante premièrement dans le rythme de
travail et deuxièmement dans le sabotage
où nous étions aidés par des commandants
des des camarades du commando français
d'étude qui nous donnaient les
possibilités de sabotter et bien ces
choses c'était une bataille c'était une
bataille constante et je pense que dans
le nombre de morts ad Dora et bien nous
pourouvons évaluer à 5 600 camarades qui
ont été pendus ou massacrés pour avoir
saboté les V2 et c'est d'une importance
extrême parce que qui sait qui sait
comment aurait tourné la phase de la
guerre si les V2 avaient arrivé à être
au point immédiatement et qu'ils avaient
fait plier le jou à l'Angleterre et bien
je je pense que ça c'est tout de même
apportter à l'actif des des déportés qui
n'étai qui n'étaient pas déshumanisés et
qui vraiment a continué la bataille et
cette bataille journalière et Dieu sait
dans quelles conditions
svp je dois dire que depuis
21h30 le Standard n'a pas cessé d'être
embouteillé jusqu'à maintenant toutes
les lignes sont occupées il faut que les
téléspectateurs aient beaucoup de
patience sils veulent que leurs question
soit posé mais avant de poser une autre
question très très importante qui
intéresse vraiment des centaines de nos
correspondants il y en a une qui doit
s'adresser à monsieur
declair qui est le soldat avec les
Américains qui a qui est entré dans un
camp est-ce que Monsieur d'cla savait ce
qu'il allait trouver en entrant à benval
et depuis quand le
savait-il la réponse est très simple
nous ne savions absolument pas
ni par les services psychologiques de
l'armée ni par quoi que ce soit et pour
nous bchenenvald a été une surprise
totale et monstrueuse car je pense pas
qu'on puisse dire un autre mot
euh ça a été un petit peu étonné que
bvald a été le premier camp je crois qui
a été découvert par les armées alliées
au moment de la rentrée en Allemagne euh
ça a été quelque chose qui
a qui je pourrais dire a un petit peu
changé l'optique
[Musique]
euh des soldats qui soient américains
français polonais ou ce que nous
voudrons mais de cette armée alliée qui
rentre en Allemagne car on nait
absolument pas idée de ça on était on
était au courant plus ou moins de de
déportation mais pour nous c'était
compiigne ou autre chose mais enfin ça
n'ait pas plus loin mais j'avoue
sincèrement que la découverte d'un camp
de concentration car c'est le mot euh
sur bchenwald a été euh quelque chose de
pour nous de monstrueux quand j'ai vu
des des piles de cadavres
entassés sur 15 m de haut et puis des
fours crématoires qui étaient encore à
moitié en route parce qu'ils étaient pas
encore
froids ça a été quelque chose
d'épouvantable
et pour répondre à la question d'une
façon
précise nous n'étions pas du tout je le
dis très sincèrement mais pas du tout au
courant de possibilité de de choses
comme ça c'était pas vrai enfin pour
nous c'était impensable et bien on l'a
vu et la première fois à
bchenenwald moi en tout cas et je pense
beaucoup de mes camarades aussi svp et
alors cette question importante et
celle-ci est-ce que les Alliés étaient
au courant est-ce que Rome était au
courant est-ce que la Croix Rouge était
au courant nous avons vu dans le film un
délégué de la Croix-Rouge qui vient
faire une visite est-ce que c'est vrai
certains de nos correspondants
prétendent qu'il n'y a jamais eu de
visite officielle de la Croix-Rouge dans
les camps d'autres disent qu'il y en a
eu quelle est la vérité qui peut
répondre à cette question qui a été
monsieur mandelb en ce qui concerne les
visites de la
Croix-Rouge je pense que personne parmi
nous ne le sait mais en ce qui
concerne la connaissance par les
services alliés de l'existence de camp
d'extermination
alors ça c'est une certitude le cardinal
patchelli qui était à l'époque légat
pontifical à Ankara il était nonce de il
était oui il était lgat pontifical à
Ankara avait
prévenu l'autorité supérieure disons les
services spéciaux américains l'OSS était
parfaitement au courant les Anglais
étaient au
courant les les organisations de de
combat en Pologne ont demandé un
bombardement au moins sur la voie ferrée
d'Auschwitz c'était une une voie unique
on savait parfaitement que c'était pas
une gare
osvchim le village le plus proche était
tout de même relativement loin et jamais
ça n'a été fait le seul bombardement qui
a été exécuté à ma connaissance par
l'aviation alliée et bien c'est le
bombardement du 24 août sur
bnwalt nous étions arrivé depuis 4 jours
nous étions au petit camp et l'aviation
anglaise a exécuté un bombardement
d'ailleurs je dois dire avec une
maestria avec une une
perfection
remarquable c'est la seule opération à
mon sens qui a été tenté par une armée
alliée contre un camp de concentration
l'envoie de tract l'envoie de tract est
que vous ne voulez quand même pas monsur
si vous permettez Monsieur le le
bombardement de bourenval effectivement
même en raison de sa
précision montre que ceux qui l'ont fait
connaissaient parfaitement les lieux
d'ailleurs il existe des documents il
existe deux photos de la RAF une prise
avant le bombardement et l'une après et
d'ailleurs au cours de ce bombardement
du 24 août 1944 c'est-à-dire le jour
même au Paris se
libéré il y a eu tout de même 400
détenus de tués et une centaine de SS de
tuer pas seul de mais ce n'était pas à
l'intérieur du camp les tous les les
détenus qui étaient au travail qui
étaient dans les commandes au travail
n'étit pas rentré au crin il y avait pas
d'abris pour eux les SS étaaiit dans les
abris mais pas eux enfin les SS pas tous
les ceux des gardes ceux des des
miradors tout ça n'était pas néta resté
en place c'est ceux qui étaient dans le
bois près des usines près des garages SS
dans la carrière alors ceux ont pris les
bombes et c'est ceux-là qui ont été tués
mais à l'intérieur du camp même il n'y a
pas eu de mort mais jeux dire oui au
sujet de la cas rouge je veux bien que
c'était vers la fin mais lorsque nous
avons fait l'évacuation de Dora vers
Ravensbruck nous sommes arrivés à
Ravensbruck nous avons fait un voyage de
de 9 jours et 9 nuits en wagon un voyage
terrible avec beaucoup de morts et
lorsque nous sommes arrivés à ravensbrck
il y avait la Croix Rouge qui se
trouvait là avec des camions et la Croix
Rouge a obtenu donné directement à Ch
un colis et elle a donné également un
colis au Russes et aux polenir enfin au
au russes qui ne faisaent pas partie de
la Croix Rouge enfin ils ont eu
également leur colollé je crois
d'ailleurs qu'il y en a beaucoup qui
sont morts parce qu'ils ont mangé le les
condensé enfin tout ça et la Croix Rouge
nous a redonné nous a fait nous a
redonné un deuxième colis quelques jours
après juste avant notre évacuation du
Grand travensbruck donc si la Croix
Rouge trou euh ah c'était à la fin oui
c'était fin mars oui enfin si la
Croix-Rouge se trouvait labas soi disant
pour un échange de de prisonnière sans
doute qu'elle connaissait le camp
svp et bien Armand jameau me dit qu'il
nous reste à peine un peu plus de 10
minutes et si tout le monde est d'accord
nous allons poser des questions sur ce
qui intéresse les téléspectateurs à
partir de la situation actuelle
c'est-à-dire 25 ans
après et la une des questions très
importantes est celle du pardon et on
pourrait la résumer ainsi d'ailleurs
c'est un correspondant anonyme qui pose
la question face à faceace avec un de
vos bourreaux SS actuellement
sentiriez-vous le droit de faire justice
vous-même qui veut répondre c'est une
question qui a été débattue souvent
longemp et à laquelle au fond personne
n'a répondu parce que il y a une chose
que l'on peut dire à la rigueur on peut
peut-être pardonner pour soi-même mais
on peut pas pardon pour les autres alors
ça c'est une question qui est totalement
insoluble il faut honnêtement dire on ne
peut pas répondre à ça mais autrement
dit si on vous pose la question plus
brutalement et plus directement est-ce
que on emploie le mot à l'égard des
bourreaux le sentiment que vous pouvez
ressentir à l'heure actuelle est-ce que
c'est le mot haine ou est-ce que c'est
le mot
pardon pardonner
c'est justice si on pouvait l'obtenir il
faut que tous ces bourau soi chat ça
c'est absolument certain maintenant si
vous parlez sur le point de vue de la
haine il s'agit ce qu'on entend par là
personnellement je dis j'ai la haine de
la haine le nazisme les SS c'était la
haine on peut pas être indifférent
vis-à-vis de la haine on peut pas non
plus avoir l'amour de la haine ça n'a
pas de sens donc j'ai la haine de la
haine j'ai la haine des SS et j'ai la
haine de ceux qui proposent maintenant
le idéologie et si j'avais un SS en face
de moi et bien si j'avais la possibilité
de faire justice moi-même je le
ferai monsieur l'abbé je voudrais
répondre par un petit fait ça se situe à
la libération du kenval qu'on a déjà un
peu évoqué tout à l'heure lorsque
sortant du revvire un ou deux jours
après j'ai repris une place dans le camp
j'étais très étonné d'une chose j'ai
trouvé une baraque du
côté le bloc 17
bien elle était pleine de
SS ce qui veut dire que au moment de
leur libération des déportés sont
trouvés encore assez maîre d'eux-même
j'allais dire à ces hommes quel que soit
le traitement qu'onurait fait subir pour
ne pas lycher exécuté à ce moment-là
leur bourreau personne ne leur aurait
reproché ils auraient pu le faire mais
peut-être qu'il n'auraiit pas été digne
d'eux-même sils avaient exécuté CSS ont
été remis à l'armée qui nous a libéré je
j'apporte une
précision j'ai participé aux opérations
militaires nous nous considérions comme
des soldats nous avons fait des
prisonniers environ
170 mais il faut préciser que ce n'était
pas les SS bourreau du camp mais des des
autres qui qu' avait les SS du camp
avait pris soin de mettre par exemple
les SS noir des des ou des autres ou
dans les dans lesémador tout ça et eux
ils sétaient débinés et les les SS que
nous avons capturé c'était des soldats
qui étaient dans la région qui étaient
dans les environs nous les avons fait
prisonniers nous les avons enfermés au
bloc 17 et nous leur avons fait aucun
mal il n'y a aucune raison mais quand la
question que j'ai répondu tout à l'heure
je répondais si j'agissait si j'avais
devant moi un sommaire le rapport fureur
le fameux SS pied de vigne ce que j'ai
vu frapper ce que j'ai vu tuer mes
camarades ce que j'ai vu agir pendant
des des mois et des mois alors je ne
sais pas si je me contiendrai unuc comme
ça pour moi c'est pas les êtres
humains je crois j'aime j'ai beaucoup
aimé la réponse de Roger Arnou
euh je crois que il faut être attentif à
la justice le dilemme dans lequel on pe
nous enfermer tout à l'heure n'est pas
vrai nous disons assez souvent un peu
comme exprimant notre pensée générale ni
haine ni oublie on veut pas oublier et
en même temps on veut la justice et je
ne pense pas que c'est le lieu ce soir
de donner des noms mais nous sommes je
pense unanimes à penser que telle ou
telle personnalité allemande
actuell toujours en vie hein lorsqu'on
évoque Tul lorsque on évoque Oradour ça
évoque aussi certains noms et bien a ces
gens-là sont en liberté ceux qui ont
fait cela c'est tout de même extrêmement
grave il y a un dénis de justice nous
nous ne pouvons pas oublier nous pouvons
pas pardonner cela non pas par rapport
comme vous disiez je crois très bien à
quelque chose de personnel que nous
aurions subi nous-mêmes mais par rapport
à ces milliers ces millions d'êtres
humains et nos camarades qui ont été
exterminés par ces gens-là on peut
pas
svp je voudrais me permettre encore deux
interventions pour terminer
la première pour poser la question
suivante est-ce que en redevenant des
hommes et des femmes libres votre vision
du monde a été modifiée et je peux même
dire qu'il y a une question qui
s'adresse directement à la béchire
est-ce que vous pensez qu'après avoir
vécu cette expérience on doit croire
encore en
Dieu Monsieur
l'abbé comme tout prêre j'ai été formé
dans des séminaires mais je crois que
comme homme d'abord et comme prêtre
c'est dans les cas de concentration que
j'été
formé il y a des chose que je ne peux
plus voir de la même façon certainement
ma vision du monde actuellement elle est
tout autre
euh l'homme d'abord quel qu'il soit
euh je pense que dans une foi chrétienne
euh on ne peut pas considérer qu'il y a
des races ou des races plus dignes et
des races indignes des sous-hommes et
des hommes supérieurs euh actuellement
je ne peux pas ouvrir un journal sans
sans être vraiment bouleversé parce
que la vie humaine qu'est-ce que c'est
400 cadavres sur le mékongo une
bagatelle et on en trouve comme ça un
peu dans tous les coins du monde or je
pense exprimer la pensée de chacun de
mes camarades par rapport au au respect
de l'homme au droit de l'homme on a une
sensibilité terrible quand on pense que
des êtres humains actuellement je ne
veux pas du tout choisir un pays en
particulier mais dans le monde et un peu
dans toutes les parties du monde des
êtres humains sont exterminés
systématiquement
euh sans aller jusque là combien de gens
et de prêtres aussi sont en prison
simplement pour des
idées la liberté de penser et de
s'exprimer n'est pas tellement grande
dans le monde d'aujourd'hui et c'està
dire mon père que votre foi personnelle
a été ébranlé absolument pas absolument
pas parce que euh je pense que cette
expérience humaine le contact avec des
hommes de de pays de races très
différentes tout cela
euh je l'ai
lu dans ma foi c'est-à-dire dans ce qui
est ce plan de Dieu sur tout homme dieu
n'a pas créé seulement des blancs il a
créé tous les êtres humains tous c cet
idéal de fraternité qui me semble être
l'essentiel de l'évangile du message de
Jésus-Christ cela il me semble que ça
colle exactement avec les besoins du
monde
d'aujourd'hui voyez euh j'ai découvert
certainement une foi beaucoup plus
profonde et j'allais dire beaucoup plus
purifiée j'étais un peu étonné de tout
ce qui a été écrit et dit même lundi
dernier parce que il a il semble là que
d'après les sorciers du ciel euh les des
êtres prêtres ou êtes croyants dans ce
monde-là c'était obligatoirement
recourir à une messe des fois très
acrobatique derrière une porte une
ordination un peu étonnante ou des
sacrements mais moi j'ai été à peu près
tout le temps sevré de tout cela je
n'étais pas prêtre encore à ce moment-là
il me restait 2 ans de séminaire à faire
mais j'ai été au contraire forcé de de
me dépouiller en quelque sorte de tout
l'extérieur d'une religion pour aboutir
à une intensité de
foi je nous revois encore avec trois ou
quatre de mes camarades nous essayions
le matin à l'appel de monter
euh sous la à l'ombre j'allais dire de
de la tour de l'entrée du camp et
pendant quelques instants bien nous
étions là recueillis par rapport et nous
prions à cause de toute cette souffrance
qui était là hein pour tous ces
camarades qui dans la journée mourrai et
moi ça cela que que l'homme soit méchant
que l'homme haïe son frère je ne vois
pas en quoi cela peut enfin pour moi
cela n'atteint absolument pas un plan de
Dieu mais je regarde le monde
actuellement en tout cas avec ce cette
aspiration à la dignité à la liberté
pour tout homme on pour ajouter
je voudrais je voudrais si vous le
permettez prendre une dernière question
qui est très importante nous a dit GUID
après malheureusement nous sommes
obligés de mettre un terme à cette
émission guarb oui pour conclure je
voudrais dire ceci nos invités ont
accepté de venir pour témoigner je dois
leur dire que leur témoignage a
certainement été largement entendu
puisque comme ça en regardant toutes les
fiches qui sont sur mon bureau je peux
vous affirmer que c'est la première fois
depuis 3 ansiste toutes les semaines
qu'il y a autant de questions en aussi
grand nombre et pour terminer je
voudrais simplement dire que dans cette
parmi ces innombrables fiches il y en a
quand même quelques-unes qui disent mais
pourquoi nous parlez-vous encore de ce
sujet après 25
ans oui je pense que c'est peut-être la
question la plus importante de la
soirée d'abord je voudrais dire à la
suite de
gens bien moi j'ai foi en l'homme depuis
que j'étais dans les cas de
concentration encore plus qu'avant parce
que précisément la résistance ces hommes
qui étaient voués à la déchéance
physique à la déchéance morale qui ont
trouvé la force de
résister de de de défendre leur dignité
d'homme et bien cela prouve que même
dans les pire
conditions il y a dans l'homme quelque
chose de grand et c'est ça qui est la
victoire de de de l'homme sur la
barbarie sur la sauvagerie qui est
exprimée par le nazisme par l'esss et si
on a besoin de témoigner comme cela
c'est parce que si cette expérience qui
a existé qui a pris fin il y a 25 ans et
bien elle pourrait recommencer si on
faisait pas attention il faut il faut
alerter avertir évidemment il y a un
aspect qu'on n pas discuté ce soir
c'était sur les causes sur les raisons
comment une chose pareille a pu se
produire parce que si on recherche
évidemment les mêmes causes produisent
les mêmes effets alors si on ne fait pas
attention à ces causes une une une chose
pareille pourrait se reproduire et elle
pourrait même se reproduire en pire et
je pense que dans la mesure où les gens
sont avertis où tous les peuples sont
avertis
alert en quelque sorte nous transmettons
un message et nous nous demandons que ce
message soit écouter pour que jamais
plus le monde ne revoie de choses
pareilles jamais plus d'chwitz jamais
plus de qu concentration bien monsieur
je vous remercie je vous remercie mesdam
je pense que je ne peux rien ajouter de
plus simplement souhaiter que votre vœux
monsieur Arnou soit exaucé et que votre
message soit entendu en tout cas je vous
remercie mesdames messieurs d'AB bien
voulu participer à cette émission j'ai
dit tout à l'heure qu'il était rare en
effet
de con de de découvrir des des anciens
déportés qui veuillent bien accepter
aussi librement que vous l'avez fait ce
soir de répondre à des questions et de
revivre un passé extrêmement douloureux
merci donc de l'avoir fait merci donc
d'avoir répondu aux questions de nos
téléspectateurs quant à vous amis
téléspectateurs j'espère que nous avons
pu répondre à toutes vos questions je
vous remercie de nous avoir prêté
attention et je vous donne rendez-vous
mercredi pour un prochain dossier de
l'écran bonsoir
[Musique]